olá a todos pessoal e que falar andar
que sejam muito bem vindos é mais um
vídeo e os tratados aqui ou wi fi ou sul
é um jogo bem 12 espera é isso aí
pessoal estou junto daquele setor
bastante ruim fica bastante assustadores
porque o jogo é tailandês é facultar não
deixe só está um lixo só vocês já sabem
meu é muito é um só - ele afirma que já
tem uma poça de sangue já tem uma luz
partida ou de música no lixo vamos
ganhar vamos lá foi dizendo que é num
estúdio de música sempre foi e não
acontece nada
o que está em jogo pessoal vejam só
esse é o nosso objetivo pessoal ir pra
casa no figura que tutoriais na pureza
chute incrível registo ou jpeg estava em
sua vez não só o meu pai tá ali koc lado
explicou que o artigo país um senhor sim
senhor de cultura serão ceifadas mas
minha mãe tá alimentá-lo e com um ar
sombrio já comove possuído portanto é
nossa é nossa mãe já tem qualquer coisa
de estranho né problema está na nossa
mãe eu fui internet o canal e vou ter
que baixar feijão todo mundo interna
será que eu consigo ficar muito
inclusive pessoal está no primeiro jogo
de terror estiver em pmp e assim
assim posso mexer em tudo tanto sua
versão isto é a primeira coisa que eu
vou fazer essa tragédia fosse bobo
cowell após ativa não é exatamente um
toque pessoal que vai aparecer um
sustinho por isso ocorrer o crime não
pressionava o assunto é sério ainda bem
que me ensinou a glicemia ou estamos
construindo [ __ ] olha só as suas
fotografias da sigatoka style deixe
muito medo muito medo vamos lá vamos lá
está tudo bem eu nem sempre é control
sistema escolas e um hospital sem uma
casa e não faço pouca idéia prato de
barro milken cujubim ainda faz panela de
barro caem nesta casa só pode ser antiga
pois faz sentido né pois esta porcaria
até aqui
o português o porto to write web sob os
olhos na grelha zone quando fui fã rum
respeito à estônia está que não
contribuiria também para jorge deus cujo
nome que o espectro de 90 news legal
universitá studi peraí vou tentar
traduzir a estudante é tua 91 cox
anúncio foi mais uma a estudante de
demonstrar isso foi em 1997 exatamente a
casa em dia é fácil sentir agora o
itaqui ma shopping campos também fiquei
pipico e charles de portugal um lavabo
óptica vai voltar para trás ainda ver
aqui mais porque a cozinha tem tudo para
fazer outra vez
[ __ ] liga decidiu isso ok essa final
não é mãe é será que o estudante só que
nós temos na casa dela é isso essa era a
foto do que o retrato que ela tava tudo
possuída eu acho que já tinha informado
de temas foram supostamente já tenho há
da pêra é só contar o shamrock ok este
tio que existiu até que os jogos pan
interativos portanto tem que ser tudo
assim o detalhe nem dar a cara num
corredor é mesmo isso que eu acho que
tudo estava o chile ainda que e acredita
que todas na briga por ajax tal e é
munida do estômago só que será campeão
eiko sétimo vida é minha dor de estômago
na cara tem um remédio pra ter feito um
chip para correr carol usam ensinar o
que lhe vai na boa aqui posso também
então eu acho que não há nada para que
neste jogo temos de tirar do haiti por
cinco ficou que curso que uma chuva de
sua irmã [ __ ] escapa do inferno
relatado por meio do nome de nokia 218
alguém e trabalho anda cá com certeza
isto mas eu quero ajudar a menina
começou a levantar mesmo ikoko espera
pra mim imagina a dor de estômago e
estou aqui pra tocar a alma se ela fugiu
pela mata para lá em destinos abrir
aquela porta não tinha que chegar às
quatro que eu acho que tem alguma coisa
não cair não só a galera só sentiram em
plenário novidades só agora agora curado
[Música]
era o jogo mudou é que tem uma porta
pessoal só pessoa muita atenção muito a
partir deste momento está tudo nas
nossas mãos é muito sangue no chão os
jogadores completamente lembro que vi
aqui uma porta nenhum treino é jogo e
outro
ai porque por uma musiquinha que tem
pegada de um cara grande papel ela cansa
mais do que o papel importante num dos
nossos filhos pegadas que aqui né
a única porta toque muito luzinha após
que vai pagar o pato fu que obrigou
ontem perseguições
eu odeio precipitando importa meu deus
a seguir surge no primeiro uma
tailandesa lá u da fazenda paredão ela
transforma-se pelas coisas de sangue que
o mpla então vou ter que sair daqui o
que será que tem alguma coisa não há
nada que eu possa usar pulseira que será
e depois só funciona pra ela né pois
claro eu acho que existe uma prisão neve
não sentisse muito estranho estão
precisando muito tranquilo só rádio não
só o dn possuir esta por um átimo
corrente psi parte da corrente com
alguma coisa né com o pecado uma tela
mais 111 qualquer coisa da época aí
acabei de entrar no sítio novo na hora
de o ubs ter revisto em baixa o tempo
total de algum bicho pega sua pizza é
isso mesmo que você vai colocar está
tudo tranqüilo porque esta cena vai para
o voto com importa que vai ficar apto
escurinho não está muito melhor este
jogo aqui está tudo tranquilo o [ __ ]
todo mundo viu possuído o lençol filme e
deu 11 artigos samurais absoluta vai co
jovem no sítio nem lembro que na casa de
banho e fechar portas fez e faz isso aí
ela vai ficar fechada por enquanto eu
acho e vamos aqui tentar ver essas
portas que não abrem é e eu não sei
posso esconder que farei com madeira
acho que estão sentindo um fato em uma
parede partida desde sua lei agora vai
dar bosta eu não vi entrar aqui eu não
devia entrar aqui porque o pecado é este
mesmo e peguei peguei pecado comunicar
sangue pode ir embora já se aproximou da
ponta de uma porta na cara cará
antropizadas em dela na não deixe só vai
embora o caps de partida de uma delas
não é exato vai pacífica para pessoal
já estou a ver um ventinho lá fora as
teve inflação eu pensava que era lá fora
né
o tempo será mal pra [ __ ] que eu
cozinho muito susto um dia em que viu o
que vai deixar uma boneca assina aqui
mas nunca levantou e levou pancada na
canela é isso que ela quer é boneca dela
thaís 30 portugal eu acho que ainda está
com dor costuma não vai mais [ __ ] é só
um jogo ainda vai ter só um jogo assim
posso arriscar a minha vida a vontade
dela desaparecer ela ou eu fingi que o
trecho sem que tudo o phishing
eu vim aqui né agora vamos esconder aqui
dentro eu não confio eu não confirme
este ouro eu você e todo falou ninguém é
o meu corpo suporta isso entrou em
funções o projeto aproveita se mantendo
em escala
gostei esta agora é de que ela venha
deixa de investigar tudo já por aí mas
com grigio certo que um circo aqui eu
acho que ela lutava pelo goleiro calero
que souto é só esperar a hora é agora é
só esperar agora deixa ela vire bem
devagar por despacho do [ __ ] brasil e
rússia time morto agora temos que
esperar que ela sair daqui e volto pro
quarto e depois nós podemos continuar a
nossa céu não é o que aponta o pixel qi
público que vai eleger a pergunta se
estou pra [ __ ]
ela quase que abriu a 14 de abril
mais uma vez a chance de isso agora o
tupi to be não sei que teve selic
ela matou um cara velho ajapi suíço
agora que o passo dado
ai ai esconde com destaque no ataque x
só por onde o sol só pra que isso tudo
conquistou conseguir pretas preta a
mesma que tá mesmo ela não viu ela não
viu carlos paiva espero que esteja que
não foi perfeita black matt bonner
estúdio de cocaína supostamente os
atuantes cuidar de um gene o [ __ ] as
frutas o test drive no braço dela ela tá
mesmo nível cai agora ela está de costas
aproveitar esconder um dique na sala que
global e isso [ __ ] sobre qualquer
ameaça que se queixou que filhos apsis
exatamente agora tem vontade
eu acho errado e chamou a atenção dela
né eu acho que é por isso que o adilson
meu caro amigo bicho tá muito tempo está
muito tenso
ela não está à venda mesmo que ela vai
ser feita em seu corpo o gol de renan
ribeiro que curso que vai ver que eu fiz
meta o fios rápido até porque agora
quando agora se o negócio como será que
vai dar
acho que abril conseguir qualquer coisa
que vai ver o que estão dizendo suau e
já nem sei estudam com um ipod abril é
rápido
po tucanos coisas o [ __ ] e até
perseguições filha da [ __ ] ontem o
segundo jogo decisivo em perseguições
carvalho da rocha de luca está dando
certo não não eu estou estressada
expressar isso vai variar agora no kuito
o preço do preso por estupro na boca não
isso não vai ser bom pro baixo e segundo
baixo ela por cima atrás de mim foi o
espírito do estupro não escapar mas não
escaparam surgiram ontem que foram ainda
hoje temos 10 só vou chegar porque este
jogo ou subirão um jogo tal eu tenho que
sair porque estava esperando mais time
mas pronto foi bom esse pessoal já sabem
quando conversar que favorito comenta em
jogos que queiram que eu joguei aqui
neste lado bom por ser dois vídeos vocês
podem ver aqui em cima vocês podem se
inscrever é só cantar nessa linha é que
nesta em 10 o quanto você vai descobrir
isto fique bem até a próxima